Democrats in Congress say they want an
investigation of the sudden firing of a
prosecutor whose office is pursuing
cases connected to President Trump
Attorney General William Barr says the
president approved his decision to
remove US attorney Jeffrey Berman in New
York Berman oversaw criminal probes of
mr. Trump's former personal attorney
Michael Cohen and Associates of his
current lawyer Rudy Giuliani catherine
herridge is at the Justice Department
Catherine do we know why Berman was like
oh well Anthony good morning Justice
Department has not offered a detailed
explanation Berman was first selected
back in 2018 by then Attorney General
Jeff Sessions who cited his more than
three decades of experience predicts a
Berman's sudden removal raises more
questions about bars independence what
did they know when did they know it and
why did they do it
Democrats say Attorney General William
bars decision to fire the US attorney
for the Southern District of New York
reeks of potential corruption he
certainly deserves impeachment but again
that's a waste of time because the
Republicans in the Senate won't look at
that the standoff began late Friday when
Barr said Berman was stepping down and
the chairman of the Securities and
Exchange Commission J Clayton was tapped
to replace him Berman had secured a
guilty plea from Michael Cohen the
president's former personal attorney and
was in the process of prosecuting two
Associates of Rudy Giuliani the
president's current lawyer however later
that evening Berman fired back against
Barr saying I have not resigned and have
no intention of resigning to do my job
on Saturday morning Berman showed up for
work in lower Manhattan a short time
later Barr said Berman was offered other
Justice Department jobs but after
indicating he had no intention of
resigning Barr wrote I have asked the
President to remove you and he has done
so before his weekend rally President
Trump said it was bars call I don't get
involved I just don't get involved but
the president has to sign a document or
I guess give it the okay Senate
Republican team Scott said he was non
concerned
removal will affect any inquiries
everyone in the DOJ works at the
pleasure of the president number one
number two there's no indication
whatsoever that whatever is being
investigated will not continue to move
on for now Berman's deputy will be the
Acting US Attorney critics point to Jake
Layton's close ties to Wall Street and
his lack of experience as a federal
prosecutor one of the president's top
allies Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
who will oversee the confirmation
process told CBS News late last night
that he will not move forward until
their sign up from the to New York
senators and both have signaled they
won't provide it Gail
a lot of layers to that story and more
to come thank you very much Catherine